okay here we are we are talking with our
first international guests doing our run
of goodbyes promise we're chatting with
filmmaker David Paul Baker he's someone
that we've known for last several years
he's um he's amazingly talented he's
pretty he's just like us he loved it he
loves to just he doesn't like he doesn't
like to wait for people anymore he just
wants to start doing the work he's he's
just like us and a sense that he wants
to do the work quickly and getting it
out there and we're just super thrilled
to have you join us yeah thank you David
great be him you know I don't think it's
that going to wait for anybody's that
nobody's answer MCOs back you know you
know and but no it's great to connect we
he's you know and I've been watching the
campaign which I know you've had a whole
break from because you're helping this
other campaign and and you know my I've
watched the other videos whether people
talking about it you know and you know
over the last a week you know and when I
first saw when I first saw I was crying
a million dollars that was the first saw
impression and I just thought but I I'm
sure that you know you're not trying to
get Moga dolls you know you know you're
not gonna you know you may you make a
movie doll say don't you know but I can
I go you know what what you were trying
to do there I knew somebody an idea that
somebody was gonna possibly that should
be over kickstarter indiegogo go go buy
never had any idea that you guys would
buying you know go that route which is
great right away so so so obviously so
the million dollars you know really sort
of you know said well look at this but I
mean so did you see this thing coming
this soon did you figure like someone
may try this but it may still be awhile
before someone sort of dives into these
waters I had an idea when I started
seeing Kickstarter campaigns we Sunday
like Seth Gordon who was gonna do doing
a book and someday I was it was that non
filmmaking and I remember seeing
Oklahoma Walt every two months ago like
somebody made that should be over
kick-start thought IndieGoGo you know I
thought cake star
and in any kind of weather my head you
know and then when I saw these guys it
was like oh I was there you know and I
thought it's great you know because just
if you finish the movie you've given the
movie and the main thing as well as as
you know it's it's not always a bit of
monetize we need many times we need me
money but it has bailed in the audience
a is the key thing there really is and
that's the way that I'm start you see
things it's not so much a bit thinking
about the cash and a bit of money in the
first place is really built in our
audience and let them see your work you
know because everybody talks about it
get fans and I don't think anybody
really has fans as such because I don't
think we've all we haven't been on here
long enough to gather fans you know like
five seven years I think you got a real
real fans when you've got body of work
up there over years they've seen you
what they've seen several films you know
what content and then you really get
fans so it's just getting kind of
supporters of that first instance that's
why I think any way to get to the point
that 1d you do get fans that really you
don't want to see your work yeah and I
think too there's a there's a definition
because we're all in this together we're
all trying to market ourselves and put
content out there and it seems like that
maybe there's a new definition it's not
even just a fan it's more of a sort of
appear you know it's like that
peer-to-peer share that well it's my
things to do if people believe even if
you know what I'm making you know calm
films and stuff with very little money
you know and you know what making a lot
of money and all her films are all kind
of rough from the edge I've just made
screen and it it's rougher an agent but
it's that way when you're showing your
potential you know wait you can turn any
in the next five years I think that's
the key it's not saying look I want to
charge you should buy this for $20 this
is you know when you've gone against
studio's net goal against this [ __ ]
I don't be sure not sparking your
potential you know that people buy an E
and then it takes it to another level
years ahead if you really push you let
me get better than u-boat fans at me can
we see a walk you know but I think it
this level is as its
patrons as people believe in you and
what which is why it's so important to
believe in you not just the walk you
know and and that's why you sometimes
when I go one way the people you know we
support my phone we retweet my farm and
they haven't even spoke to me ever you
know and then one may support a phone my
retweet up you know me ladies guys we've
been connecting for a bad turn off years
three years similar what other people
online you know I know you can't push
everybody but I tend towards the people
that of northern for three years that I
know that you only stuck in it that
oppression they're trying to get
somewhere else trying to do something so
you know it's a thank you that's level
is believing in people you know and
which cake stout really and Andy Hogan
was about really isn't it you know yeah
yeah and I think too were in a new age
where now we can tweet like you know act
so and so and it's it's whereas before
we had to go and find their address at
the library like you were talking about
earlier and find out like I remember
years ago I wanted to write Michael land
in a letter when I was a kid Perry and
it's just like where do you find this
you know this is a long time ago now we
can just go on Twitter and just maybe
get a conversation started and another
thing too I mean because it's so people
are so accessible online or their PR
people are we feel like they're talking
to to the star there but also to now
we've also kind of become enthralled
with each other's stories and so getting
these new acquaintances online you know
maybe they're not friends maybe they're
not fans but there may be acquaintances
and we're all like interested in their
story and so that's another way to kind
of gain an audience when you know
they're artists themselves so it's an
interesting time and I mean the SSL
point you bring up because it's quite a
strange thing I remember when I was in
Oklahoma last year you know didn't
screen and I was talking to Oklahoma
Ward who's a filmmaker for people that
don't know and we were talking about
stuff and I was talking about it's very
strange that communities can I come
together near no way it's great and I
know weights can I bad you know because
that way it's almost like comfort zone
everybody can i congregates together I
seen other communities are seeing
business communities to see and
these sports communities and filmmaker
communities that come together slightly
like a comfort zone and and are way that
if a few went to a high street and then
the high street I was for hairdressers
and then the hairdresser started to come
each other's hair dress in place and
started fund each other it'd be really
it's a really bad way the things you
know if I'm a business but in the up so
I at first I can get my head Verena when
filmmakers a hell told me because I just
thought as filmmakers been really bad
business people because you know but
then and they ever said what you see
there are so many bad movies are so many
much bad content means in the world
Hollywood independence that you want to
end up inspiring each other and pushing
it be better you know so in a way if you
can I reason a bar if you help each
other you're trying to create something
you know there's bad in the industry
there's Bevan it's different for
Hollywood is definitely so-and-so so in
a way kind of levels up you know but at
the same time I think with a future
ahead people are gonna start spreading
to where they need to get their
audiences whether you know if you're
gonna make a genre movie a crate movie
if you're gonna make sportsmen you've
got those communities and you really
build a the fans there you know rather
than stealing what can a comfort zone
you know that's what's gonna evolve and
the time ahead you know
yeah is that where that's saying no
man's a prophet in his own land kind of
a same time because in some sense it's
it's almost like yeah it's like leaving
your hometown a little bit like maybe
you were nothing there but if you kind
of pull out then you're able to kind of
reestablish yourself and and kind of
become a new person is that sort of what
you're saying well yeah and the thing as
I understand the reason for as well
because if you're a filmmaker 11 breathe
felon so your subject matter where you
can converse about what you can tweet
about is about that so you only end up
attracting the same people you know but
when I go to communities that are only
actually watching movies and wofe holler
movies especially horror fans are going
horror conventions that just talk a bit
movies they don't talk about making
movies they don't talk about cameras a
lot of a crowdfunded it's
movie so his as found me because there's
those people that we want to be we're
fine if you know what I mean that you
want to get those people that love you
though so anyway I think it's a good
balance between both by thing as
filmmakers we spread to favor real
communities for the type of work that
we're going to you know over the next
year's and I think I've evolved that
week and every community does as I've
said I've seen sports communities
recently I was in a business community
or in Twitter online and do it or can a
condo getting together as well learning
from each other you know and so it's
just it's just what everybody does
really you know one thing we got
frustrated with on our side David is um
you know and I wonder if you've also
kind of experienced this because you
know you have mission x which is a film
that's completed and now you have the
movie screen which i think is you know
you're starting to get some feedback on
that i think you still have some more
tweaks to do maybe with audio and some
more volume actually before it's totally
ready but on our side you know our first
o night for the wedding you know we have
on amazon currently and now you know and
then as we got ready to release this
film you know really for small films
like the one we've made and maybe like
some of the films you've recently made
it's like you know there's not you know
it's difficult it's difficult like
people don't realize the challenge of
just you know and the money involved in
getting in on these various platforms so
it becomes really frustrating you know
and and and and as we looked at it were
just like really more than anything you
know we just want to put it online
nice and easy simple so that people can
access it and just like you said before
we came on you know before my live with
this broadcast you talked about just
putting it out there and seeing if you
can sort of create that a snowball
create that that thing where you just
have it in motion and just push it
forward and and we and we really felt
for this small film of ours that that
was definitely the best option we don't
have the money resources to compete with
Hollywood to go the theatrical route we
don't have the patience right now to see
what would happen on the film festival
in the film festival world yeah yeah we
just we just want to do this
surely a world well Gregory be made a
good point
quia
because always you evaluate Gregory and
as he speaks all stuff that I cannot
believe we are you don't just make the
walk to try and sell and to make the
work you make the work and the more that
you make the more productive that you
get and what people see your work you
attract these other eyeballs he attract
these other people in the industry we
may be freelance jobs but if you've got
a felon and you've got a it's taking
years thinking you're gonna have to make
it you know I'm speaking from one
experience here and he's taking another
year together
yeah and it's natan minutes content it's
90 minutes to you walk over the space of
three years that's those three years
that nobody has seen you that no
opportunities are coming ahead you know
what so i think and that's why you know
over the last few weeks we've been
talking about youtube was and i think i
get my cell instead some things that
want to be a youtuber and there's
nothing about that youtubers are doing
great stuff as always thought is really
annoying when you sweat you have a
channel and it's a screaming it you know
but there's a lot to bill and for them
because they'll get them worker there
every single week you can i bows that
both on our audience they get
opportunities that's come along then
making money and i think it's really
important to get a model it's nor
youtube more if you want to be an
independent filmmaker but not
independent from me but some hybrid
between both where you may not water
content and good content but again it
fast and the more that people are seeing
your work you know the more you're
really gonna build real fans and other
opportunities come on and that's when
you have this thought that's when you
stop worrying a bit monetizing because
it's just like tire of Facebook you are
Instagram or Pinterest asleep I think if
you think of it monetizing at the very
start you know that's when you're going
to be in trouble I think it's both in
the audience and you have to focus and
that's why I'm always so adamant about
making movies for as cheap as possible
because if you meet was cheap as
possible I mean mission x and screen
really to be honest the better I made
them to land you know if you take guys
that Ridley Scott before he even touched
his first feature phone he made
something like 2,000 TV commercials so
he know how he knew her movie you know
he's not rate I bet he knew holy [ __ ]
you know before he even came across
speech I saw
we out me three feature films but I
still feel like an infant I still feel
like an amateur completely even though
I've learned a lot so might shoot over
the last few years these chains mention
extras really I want to make a film I
want to win I want to get there you know
I want to make screen I'll end the hell
of a war and scream no and have you hear
that when they [ __ ] I'll and hurry and
then people were seen if you say we if
you see you're gonna do this and you do
that people know that if I gave her
money he's gonna do that you know so you
know the reputation and I think it
that's what we need so we need to make
more work you know quality walk but we
need more of that and we need to get
there we need though the audience and
League regular beings talking these
other opportunity to come on you know
and cuz some you know somebody it's
message me today in series a bit my
shirt fell on he'll take my short film
it that she'll start charging friend and
then it's like Jesus
you know leisure trip was a short films
or every single week for free you know
and you're putting one film that then
you think imma charging for as they get
the walk meet and get there and that's
why I've can I change my to the last six
months with a way doing this other
project where instead of make a lot
content what walk he says it's that we
as a creative person that you it's the
kind of strange business we're you know
very creative for very long if you make
a phone you may be shooting sex these 21
days buying you're in post-production
you're creative but you get back 18 once
we link reels you know I think it should
be like 70% you're creative and 30% you
know you're selling you're doing all
that sort of boring stuff that you've
got you do then if you get internet you
get that sake when you're finished bang
it goes you know we can any faster was
you know we can anybody can back to you
your nowait me just go straight away you
create so it's like or place to talk
years ago 20 years ago Frances for
cornices it's gonna become more than
that form and I think that's because if
it's small contained and you're fasting
you mean like a youtuber basis you get
the same spurs on independent filmmaker
then you meet that and you get out there
you build the audience and if you both
the audience and you want to make a
Breaking Bad in seven years time you get
mo you people you can go I want to make
a spec television seen it you know
that's the kind of way that I think it's
just making more what can I make some
more fun you know happens awake t move
fast like a peanut do things and it's so
frustrating the way that things are done
you know they it's kind of the old model
the way ASEA you know how do you feel in
terms of making a foam the way entertain
you know do you get I start feeling the
frustration about how long as an yeah
well I think Karen has something and
then I'll jump in our answer that
thought there David yeah and it was just
it sounds like you have like 50% artists
and then 50% businessman inside of you
and I don't know maybe we talked about
this before but was that always the case
or did you just see from watching that
there were so many people that just
wanted to make great art and they didn't
want to do anything with it after that
no I was I've never I never had a
business end and over the years but what
I had to say dear when I used to write
scripts and I'd put them in the drawer
and I'll script and written they don't
go well if I get so bad in this lake and
look for money that's killing my
creative say but those scripts will
never be meet if I don't get the
business st. you know what the thing I
want to do in next year say ascend it's
very much I'm not talking about I'm not
jumping I'm just making a point here
that it's a it's a world that is can a
business like but inside that world the
content is free of very creative it's
within an infrastructure and I think if
we can get noesis it's I think it's just
creating asleep we are for me personally
an example I came up with screen six
years ago know when I know that same
thing gets me
I'm before I'm ready should I'm done the
fact if you know what I mean because it
was six years ago
the Webster I've got no I've just came
fresh in the last few months I've got
some old stories but I don't way get
them too early
just keep them that way keep them cannot
I don't completely ignore them so that
when I go meet them with the fresh that
exciting the spontaneous and then when
untamed vation post bang the gore the
world so the fresh ain't boredom of them
if it was more creative anyway the next
thing you know so it's it's not even
from a business point if you now think
and actually get more content in the
money is more from a crib if you take
any business again we are these
platforms are Facebook they were never
designed to meet Bell means you know
what the key McCausland be accident work
it was never designed thinking it's
gonna meet Boeing's but if you're they
solve a problem and for me personally
solving a problem it'd be more creative
and I mean you realize if you're more
creative there's more of it as that
chance set is trying to just meet money
as well because you're gonna build an
audience so I think you have to have a
faint bounds between creative and
business you know and and I think the
problem has everybody just looks to
monetize and make money first you know
and I think we realized that it's a long
long what you know I realized that and I
mean that's why I think you know me
that's only my opinion you know I'm
standing well nobody else yeah I think I
think you know I think we come to a lot
of the same conclusions David you know I
certainly see the future that lies ahead
for independent filmmakers that are
gonna have that sort of you know that
are gonna really go to sustain
themselves I think a lot of them are
gonna have their ties you know on to
YouTube and they're gonna sort of
utilize YouTube in addition to sort of
you know the films that they create I
mean if you look at someone like Freddie
Wong it's really remarkable what he's
been able to do because you know pretty
much as far as I know every video he
puts online brings him about ten
thousand dollars recently he asked you
know his Kickstarter campaign from like
a year or two ago I mean he asked for
75,000 he was able to raise $300,000 to
make that film are going to make the
webseries video game high school and
then it's like each episode he releases
is churning out $10,000 at least you
know that you know I don't even know how
much money he's getting for you know I
mean there's at least that money that
there's at least that much money coming
through so that's pretty wild you know
we don't necessarily know a lot of
people in independent film world where
another content that was content and
having that much revenue come through
obviously yeah it really has to pay his
whole crew and he's got that and the
whole deal so it's not all in his pocket
but he's but he's earning his living
doing what he loves to do but the reason
they uture was of course
Vantage against us as well again because
when you speak to most youtubers I know
you spoke to them what I've saw and
lanús they just have so much fun
they don't actually feel the gay ever
had any hope I get into Hollywood I've
been noticed by Hollywood so that I
rewards
so that's dead they just make [ __ ] for
fun which really should for fun so they
make it for fun and they make moreover
the problem and independent filmmakers
as they don't really know where the one
may you could say what do you want as a
filmmaker or I want to be successful I
wanted Hollywood I don't want to go to
Sundance and it's so that's just a very
general desire that's no defining what
you want you know before you know what
you want you know you've got you aware
that you'd really cut the [ __ ] you
wanna walk in Hollywood or do you want
to get watts or do you the money that
you know what you want go no I don't I
don't care about what's I don't gonna
share a follow it then I can take that
route but then you go 100 percent if we
don't go 100 percent in a certain way if
you 100% that you want to walk in city
of films and you spend seven years
trying to do a trailer for a sci-fi
movie that maybe you know especially do
fame but know exactly where you want to
go Vince and as youtubers they don't
even fact that we they just think I'm
making this [ __ ] for fun so they don't
and we we get drawn understand our eyes
but independent filmmakers in general I
getting these cannot magnetic draws
towards Hollywood or Sundance or Ryland
just coming for the point I'm making
stuff because that it [ __ ] lover you
know and and like when I made screen
last year is he even I'm not gonna make
a horror films gonna make money it was
more a knee jumper my comfort zone I
think what they all say the world with
the a money you make a film I'm gonna
help well how you shoot myself when I
will have different skills and it's that
fun aspect you know and and I'm not
gonna spend a hundred 200 grand or
somebody's money because I don't know
really what I'm gonna do yet you know I
had a plan for a drive and stuff but I
can I change because the internet
changing evolving nope not these new
opportunities you know but it's just
that I think it's that we back to it you
know it says something that's that
equation a fault that a [ __ ] hell
when it was
I take another route and the by two I
was told what was talking about was a
it's important to know where you want to
go you know and you make a clear
decision we get bright by promise on
IndieGoGo bang we're going that way and
that's why my own about that you know
you mean it says you know and it wasn't
you know should we try this with make a
first there was a mate gay it was like
no that's we were gone whatever happens
you know and I think that's the right
way to go you know what thanks and by
the way let me just say the reason we're
wearing these hats and today's did his
birthday so for seventy-two Dick Clark
taught him a lot that's that's why but
and you know and I like what you said to
David earlier that you you kind of fell
in talking with Oklahoma and Nicki that
you know someone was probably going to
do this and when he told me when David
told me the idea I was afraid that
someone would get to it before yeah
actually launched it and I and I know
with David he likes to think about
things really really carefully with me I
think I'm more like okay let's do this
now so I think there was that pressure
to get it out there because I felt too
even though this was David's idea I felt
that probably someone's going to do this
that and that it was only a matter of
time before he do have well let me let
me jump in there because with this idea
this idea with this idea I really wanted
to go and I want to get this thing
started
so well what happened our on our end is
our very first review was from the LA
Times and so it was a really really
favorable positive glowing review that
we weren't anticipating for our small
little movie you know it's like it's
almost like striking the jackpot like
right off the bat and so all of a sudden
and then as we screamed it at the
downtown independent that first week you
know the this is the small little movie
of ours was really affecting people you
know and and so you know when you're
making a film you have do you have those
kind of hopes that you know that maybe
something here is going to you know it's
going to connect with those that are
seeing it you know and we started to get
that reaction for people that that
people are being impacted it's rough
around the edges it's not for everybody
but but you know it was it was
it was still performing a lot better
than we ever thought it would you know
so then all of a sudden were thinking
like okay well maybe maybe you know we
started people started getting in our
ear like hey maybe you guys should look
at New York you know maybe maybe you
guys can get a percentage deal at a New
York theater and you won't have to pay
anything upfront maybe because the LA
Times and the response so far so so we
spent like a month and a half New York
San Francisco
Austin Seattle and that was Karen and
Gregor doing all that work right calling
everybody and at the end of the day it
didn't go through because we didn't have
the money that's the bottom line like
all of a sudden they were interested to
start you know it's when they heard LA
Times they're interested but then as
soon as we don't follow through with any
money all of a sudden the emails don't
come back the phone calls don't come
back and I was getting really anxious
I'm like look I don't want to keep
wasting time like hoping for a bit for
this city or this city or this film
festival like other people like you
shouldn't you should submit the AFI you
should submit the Toronto you should
submit the Tribeca and it's just like
you know I want to get this thing out to
the people
I felt I felt this was the way to do it
so you know with this particular idea I
was I was like I didn't I didn't want to
keep dragging along so there was that
aspect of it but then there was also
another aspect that was really scary and
so it was almost like a release or a
relief because the initial plan was
after our one-week run in June the plan
was okay like after the one-week then
BAM were right online so you know
there's another aspect of it where I was
actually kind of relief to me because
here we are we're jumping in a new
territory maybe we weren't quite ready
at the time to do this and oh you know
it kind of like took a little pressure
off me
to have to go from the one-week run
pushing that to all of a sudden having
to jump into this right away so it's
been this weird dynamic that I've been
facing yet I think I gained this point I
think we know what you want because you
know we all get told people tell you try
this festival go that festival go here
and go the any go will win why you might
why am I doing this okay I think if
you've and raised a lot of money for
investors and you're comfortable that
there
take it to the conventional roots and
get sales agents in a room distributors
in that room their sales agent and
better than again staff you know at
least a half a million dollars or
something then can i traditional you
know yeah I can understand that but when
you've made something for a small or no
budget if you've made it from
crowdfunding like I'm your screen then
there's a way you can kind of give it
back to the people you know in Canal and
building the audience again so it's less
but if you have raised money or if you
want to go eat festivals because you do
want to Train go all the way Korean you
want to train your north by the end if
that's really what you want I think it's
just knowing what you want but I think
people too many people go I'm going away
this festival I've got you to take my
shorty that's festival I've got a play
that's best one it's like life is
[ __ ] short you know it's like it's
that you know it's like that you know
the way that you look at life I don't
think people contend and think about it
enough to what do you want why you
submitting it Mia and it's almost that
that's what you do you know but the
world would this change you've got to
start thinking a different way you know
because everything's completely jeans so
I think that's you know and that's why I
again my admired about we've done just
bang gaudiya and do it and just do it
and I think that's what more people need
to do in the future just define what you
what you really want to get an audience
you want to guess a career is that you
know exposure is that you know and it
end the deal you know if you do get your
work at the end you build an audience
over the years you more lately getting
moist if you do want to get noticed by
the industry as well if you get half a
million people 100,000 people behind you
you know that you're going in front of
them and you come to the table we a
better deal to make something whereas if
you're turning in that door everybody
else is trying to get on your vein that
big crowd you know so are still leads
back to the same place if you want to
whatever you want to work really you
know but I think it's just and me
personally I don't don't people that
don't they go the first of all of our
I've no opinion the earth depends and
each person's circumstances and phone
for me personally means nothing to me I
submitted to festivals no reason Assad
married was because I see was agent saw
screen and they make they distribute
really bad movies but if your names on
them my name is Shane movies they don't
care if I movie
great the only care is gone a minute
because they can sell 200,000 DVDs as
you know I works so the advice this the
madness festive again near them or take
a underst
[ __ ] that you know it's like so ident I
said married and and it there's no
there's no way that screen is gonna make
any impact when Iran or whatever you
know because it was industry movies you
know and I regret it's a net net but
it's no big deal
but I've no desire to any festivals but
I gained I made this movie for nothing
you know and it's great funding so I can
afford to do it up you know and it's
tight you know I want I want to move
through things I don't want to send Lee
you know cuz your spirit your spirit
gets killed your spirit dies the more
that you're sitting in your weight in
this industry you won't keep that away
if you would keep moving that's all we
ask these things anyway you know because
the morally you don't move as you guys
all know one wants told me because the
more that you don't move you started
from sure but you're so you start to
feel my feet and I make movies you know
where's that kind of [ __ ] petrol you
know obviously you know that's the way I
feel anyway you know it's sorry no I saw
it on you become I'm serious man that's
something you said I'm going slightly
off-topic but you said that the world
has changed you remember what time that
was that it changed I realized the world
changed gradually you know as we go
along it every year in everyone's
lifetime but in our sort of you know as
we became adults what do you think that
change actually took place we're really
turned a corner for good or bad I think
you it it wasn't just a the Congress and
I think it was social media because with
fairness you know definitely in social
media you know in my space every years
ago because I was originally gonna take
screen across America where myspace
account with drive-ins and stuff and I
remember watching it years ago
seventy years ago it was the first movie
and the UK that was streamed on a
website you know and what Jesus crazy
and say that I feel sorry for today I'm
sorry for today but because we're about
older we've got the experience to the
other world I mean a movie the
conventional way the first movie was
short in film there was no real internet
you know I've got experience a nice
rocking afar got a bad deal and Twitter
or think this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
is not what you know I can reclaim my
that when I used to watch a picture
coming down the page and it took half an
hour on the picture you know young young
people that are so used to all these
tools that take them for granted you
know I've got a red can I can show a
movie because I need this on the
distribution that's gonna be asking a
tougher on them but if you come for the
old skill you're like a kid in a sweet
shop you can still see how exciting the
stuffers and you've got you keep
reminding yourself you know so I think
over the last I think 12 you know really
and and actually even till recently
you know I said screen to Oklahoma wards
in fact no I had you know to the Bacchus
in Oaks is they put screen you know any
studio on a big screen on a female Kent
you know I never side three gabay fail
the upload it and he sat back and says
we're really are in a different thing
because it looks exactly the way they
looked at him after that the same way
you know and Elaine it's always you know
you just you get a point where you gonna
[ __ ] how everybody's watching the
stuff on iPads and phones and these
screens
you know you get point we just that's
why I stopped mouth originally the idea
to take screen across drive-ins America
and then I thought but I need to I
campaign raised a lot of money and and
I'm not really gonna enjoy the trip
because I'm done with a movie if you
know what I mean there's something that
conceived years ago and then when I saw
the internet I saw the new ways and I
come up with this other idea that's more
fun that's more exciting you know I'm
still gonna get screen over there in
different ways but it's just what what
changing so fast every six months you
know but I don't think no matter what I
think even a Facebook disappeared in
three years time or Twitter or whatever
I think the one fundamental thing is
gonna steered seem you know both in the
audience even if we're by T email
addresses you know which is really which
is more important than anything else
anyway you know galleries unions and
that's what I think you know I don't I
don't think it's good to protect too far
ends you know because things are
constantly changing
you know but you feel with social media
that was really the turning point yeah
and yeah well social media the turning
point for real creative freedom because
with social media you could with the
cameras were so good enough that you
know you can make a film several years
ago make you very cheaply and take it to
the industry if you want to get noticed
by the industry and yet you could still
do that
you know the social media took it to a
level where you can go
I can cut these people and may take me
several years you know but I can really
I don't need them you know and then if I
wanted me walk we a begger canvas in
five years I've got an audience Laker
says then they have to come we're deal
where you don't come we are less than
hundred things that have to do for them
because I've I've got an audience they
can just leave me just give me the money
and leave me move that do here you know
so it's that creative freedom this to me
for social media it's not so much the
technology with the cameras you know
it's that you can cut these people and
direct to the audience and it's creeped
up you know over the last three years I
think you know really I think so when
you know and but to me it's just that I
keep remain you know no matter we all
get this we read you know if you see me
out you know and then you go and they
actually remained in my cell you know
but a few years ago Quint
it was just email you know and there was
like oh there's nobody on internet I'm
sure me it's you know you know it was
like you know there was like fifty
thousand websites know that one are gone
so yes
Tamizh but it's always preemies and I
was less than an interviewee is a Ronnie
page that Google and Charlie Royce was
asking a bit Internet and how its
evolved how far'd he think it's evolved
and he says it's one percent where it's
gonna be you know and I can agree
there's another way of always beyond
what we can we can imagine you know that
I think it's gonna involve too you know
wow it's kind of scary yeah yeah like we
were just saying the other day
exhilarating and scary at the same time
mm-hm yeah yeah but it's as I'm as a
marathon it's not a sprint
you know I think everybody wants to
sprint and they don't you know I sound
46 years old and I I want to make this
other content so I can build an audience
is it the content that really just loved
to do though my whole life not gonna be
Fame doing I'm creative them working but
in 10 years time you know roughly six
years old at late unique back TV seniors
are completely controlled for audience
finances at Bell a big enough audience
or a big action movie you know but
definitely an action movie The Hollywood
would never ever make and go okay if in
ten years time I'll be 56 years old well
friendly Scott 76 knees making movies
that's nothing you know if you're really
in it for life and it's your work and
it's your passion you've got to start
preparing know for what you want to do
in five in ten years thing you know
that's the way I see it and really take
it serious rather than you know it's you
know I can see where it's gonna I think
I can see where it's gonna go you know
but and it's fast mean it's gonna be
needing felt you know that's naturally
gonna filter itself because when people
realize that you can't just make
something and put you know within a week
make something with on a week and put
out there aren't gonna realize that the
ones that are in it for the long term
are gonna be there you know and the ones
I'm not gonna drift you know it's a
whole thing you know or some missile
board brains a you know is there
anything you can speak on David in terms
of you know how you how you're going to
begin to craft city of sin and how
you're going to utilize YouTube and and
maybe how that impacts on any future
full-length you know films that are
gonna work on you know can you just
summarize just to summarize very very
quickly and simplify it as simple as
possible it's really just about a
thought universe like the way the
Twilight zones got universe you know but
no web series you know because I like
the idea and meek and it's like it's
just like movies but their main movies
you know at 45 minutes long 30 minute
long longer content and these 12 of
these will be in this won't and one of
them once is released you know I'll make
them and release
one every single month but to promote
one each month so you know nobody's
written and you'll have for a movie
again every month but also each day you
know there'll be pictures the gory
Instagram that connected with a movie
brandied say yes and pictures so that
it's the one website it's the one I
don't have to keep making a new website
for a new movie or a new story is
constantly they are promoting to one
destination so if I start about fans for
a hole a doughnut and crema that they
don't just coming out one destination so
they'll be one low movie released every
single month we already spent off videos
that are don't know marketing values
they're not promoting that that actually
teasers they tell you what wine goes for
characters that you don't see in the
main story so it tease you towards that
so by the time the end of the month
comes that these pictures on Instagram
going to Facebook page and videos people
are the idea is to get them teased up
there for that you know and then so that
content at first I was gonna give the
main content for free the main film
every month for free as well but when I
look at what youtubers make they make
I'm value every month or every no every
week I find putting a few values I'm
probably gonna end up making more
content than youtubers you know so that
content can be free you know but if I
charge $1 for the every single month you
know for each movie and people like and
then they come the next month to see the
next film so as that starts that bail
vest is a plan anyway that's that's the
boding draw and in the actors people are
working on earlier they're building
their social media they're promoting
that brand is say it's helping them or
promoting each other if it starts to
grow and the first year anyway I want to
establish this world and the quarantine
and in the stale of that you know and
then have a
Dhokla home a water wanna do a story
because of what queer Maliki's work and
warm but if it starts to grow then I
bring of other filmmakers one and make a
film they can make maybe crowdfunding
but then say yes mmm both that goes and
say yes end yeah well deal there's
promoting a folk primordium work and it
fells that what if a filmmaker wants to
make a film in Paris say haste
45 minutes story you know I well quirky
story they make it there it goes and say
I said you know it's I'm coming I'm not
trying to make a platform here for a
phone me because
some know that Unseld to selfish I'm
trying to make just like youtubers do
about a fanbase my walk Faust
but if it grows you know I want to be
making more content so I can't make
films every single you know instead of
one someone that may come at once a week
a felon so I need more people but by
that time I'll be established of spot
people that are good if they want to put
a what cameo in this course promoting
each other and just bail that's one
destination you know over several years
and if it really grows on a several
moment people on that and they loved the
walk genre fans horror fans and
definitely defecates as your honors
personal movies that cannot develop and
now and categories then I love content
like a big movie or a big TV see you can
be creating three five years time and
I'm not I think that organic we've real
things are not planned like a structure
like a business planning the the genesis
that comes from as one of me content
fast to be creative to go and shoot for
three months non-stop because when I
show a screen if I really took all
together a short with NC 70s that was
there for longer but you know I can
assure in seventies so if I can make all
this content really fast and Annika's
edited then it's putting a lot of work
for the whole year and it's just both in
that one destination so that's really
it's coming from a creative point of
view but then when you do that other
things open up I can arrest seat for it
so you see that other revenue sources
can command so naturally from a business
say can just develop itself and I think
that's the best business ideas where
you're not trying to make money but
you're trying to solve a problem and
then if you solve a problem then I think
that can take care itself because you're
both an audience you know that's the
plan area anyway of me you know and I'm
gonna try it you know and just have fun
way you know and see if I can get it
going because it's just that everybody
Stephan simply way make a phone during
festivals for year to wait to travel
they like to go you know other draw like
travel and meet what you know so that's
the sort idea really you know I mean it
sounds really encompassing especially
someone who's building this up on the
ground up I mean how how overwhelming is
it for you David to take all this enemy
are
you overwhelmed by everything you're
describing there or you feel like no
this is this is where I'm going
no M no yeah of course you know the
thing you need in this life is teams to
eat teams of people but when you stop
not you have to do a lot yourself to get
to that point and people started seeing
you're doing if you got waiting for
something to start your confidence I
mean the one they want to work on as
well so I need all the team as well but
I think doing screen last year really
was my wake-up call that when I was
shooting with a 5d and I was shooting
fast and really once the time there was
no crew at all we just mean the two
actresses you know and I realized then
it was almost like I'm an independent
filmmakers like a youtuber you know and
speed and the quality is there okay
unsaved and stuff you know and this will
have won't be a crew that stay and you
know play it's that speeding that
mediate seeing getting things done fast
they actually enjoy working that way so
then scream last year the late bulb came
on main lessees one wanted to because it
can I can do this I know how you do this
you know and and shouldn't if I go yes
ayyy I'm [ __ ] once story in a city
that's contained you know pretty much
the one place and therefore go you wait
in Las Vegas I'm shooting sex stories
the other than the ones say so what you
know you're shooting within weeks a lot
of stuff but I realized stuff you know
I've always stuff for years so I wait to
what I like to work fast you know it
just if I don't what fast I won't last
in those business you know because it's
just - it's like dawn so it's really you
know it's coming from that say it's not
right think of it making money but if it
works they'll probably naturally meet
money sell because if you're both an
audience people believe in you the one
you make more work so they gave you
money make more what you know and I
think experiences are important in the
future if you can give people
experiences and not just any material
its wake
there's a few things in this where
people come can come along yeah partly
in a scene in Las Vegas 200 people it
can be in the scene you know and you can
shoot there and it sparked an experience
for a lot because I sometimes forget
that who the hell would want
come on a film or be an extra because
it's to me it's one of them was boring
places to be unless you're actually
making phone you know you know it's like
it's like
it was nothing exciting good unless
you're making a you know and but any
forgetting no people do want to be part
of that you know it's fun if you if you
don't do that you know if you're not
evolved or not so that's this all ideas
here it goes anyway you know
so which wish your ideal after your
that's phone but what have you changed
because I know you're talking about
youtubers a lot of you change that
you're actually still want to make
features at least don't wanna if you
want to go a different Road or web
series or what what can I really just
want to take we haven't we haven't fully
committed ourselves yet you know for now
yeah one thing I did get a chance to
touch on is you know with goodbye
promise I mean this film was something
that we literally started a month I
think after we started our film courage
radio show so it's like as we've kind of
add some courage became its own thing
yeah that was happening we were also
filming this movie and and and
crowdfunding forward and and then you
know trying to work our way through the
post-production process that it's been
it's been really overwhelming it's it's
been really ruling to do everything we
do with film Kerr is and the amount of
emails that come through that don't
Karen's answering all emails and then
trying to handle the social media and
interact with people and build an
audience so it's like as we're finishing
this film and as we're releasing it it's
like we're completely exhausted you know
we haven't had time really you know you
know you know I've had plenty of ideas
in terms of like there's there's a lot
more work that's there that it's like
this is a great idea I love this idea
and I love this idea so there's a lot of
there's plenty of ideas that we've
written down some thoughts on nothing
that we've developed fully all the way
you know we're definitely learning a lot
from from when we look at what's
happening at independent film there we
go when we look at what's happening on
YouTube we see some very exciting
opportunities there you know it's it's
hard it's hard to point a certain
direction until after these 22 days or
up or whatever we're down so I think
we're down to 20 20 to 21 days on our on
our goodbye promise release so we have
to see like because you know what this
rest thing is
we started to push really hard we're
offering the film for $1 and after five
days I think it was we crossed a
thousand dollar threshold which is like
wow this is really crazy when you're off
your home for a dollar and a few days
later you're going over a thousand
dollars but then we made the tough
decision you know and it's it seems you
know whatever it seems like but we made
the decision of like hey you know what
we're gonna we're gonna hold off pushing
our own film because we're so compelled
by this filmmaker Chicago who wants to
make a movie before he goes blind you
know and for me it's like my mom my mom
and dad are both deaf I've thrown up you
know with impairment and it's just like
you know what it just it just really
touches me it's just a story that really
touches me to think that there's this
guy that is talented has proven he's
talented he has the short window of time
young yes knowing that he's has this
this impending blindness for since he
was what seven years old
yeah he's but you know it's obviously
something since childhood
yeah and so he knows that there's a
ticking clock and he wants to do this so
you know it was just the right thing to
do and we've seen in our own lives or
last few years that it just becomes so
so precious you know there's people that
we know right now this minute that are
dealing with some serious life
circumstances some life challenges you
know we've known as people that we've
met that we know in our lives that have
tragically passed away just in the last
couple weeks so there's all this stuff
weighing on us you know so for the right
now in this moment of time it's just
like you know we're gonna we're doing
all we can to see Jack see this goal
through so we're gonna push it through
today through tomorrow he's got about
$65,000 to raise and we're just gonna go
all out
where we've been doing that all week and
then we'll come back to goodbye promise
we'll push that with all our power think
everybody's going to come back to
goodbye promise as well because you've
stolen 20 days left you know yeah and I
think people come by and pushy and I was
telling about their impression you know
and so I think you've only got good
pressure and they're definitely you know
yeah I've seen that campaign
you know because I'm so you know I don't
mean a tough bastard I mean but you know
I don't usually get caught no more
things and I've seen other people having
the same who is slightly a lot motional
blackmail when a few weeks ago but then
in the last few days in the last week I
seen I looked at the guys you know a
scratch and he's walk and he's a script
rate there's a lot of people gonna do a
camera they don't get me down with him
so what I make him appear only in the
try and sell he's a script writer you
dedicate to what he's doing does that
say we go okay let's forget just about
there Blane save a little but this is a
guy who looks like he's going to great
phone me can if he only gets to meet one
movie you could continue reading scripts
to I mean so have some support there you
know I know it's a lot of money and
people to say well why isn't or less
money you know because you can meet a
movie for less but if he has gonna make
maybe just you know God for a buddy
gonna make one movie then I would
probably go for that level as well you
know because if you know you know and so
I'll be pushing it and they you know
appreciate all day tomorrow to the last
month you know you know I guess I guess
you know you know we also relate to it
in the sense that you know we ourselves
have set that a possible goal you know
goodbye promise the movie itself is
about a man who's chasing the impossible
goal of coming you know there's so many
people that we know that come to LA and
it's just like you know we all have this
level of ambition and so it just ties in
to what we're doing you know and and ya
know even though we have our own
impossible release that's underway it's
just like you know the thought of like
just letting that campaign die when you
when you think like you know what you
could have got behind it we could have
maybe just we could at least see what we
could have done you know like as long as
we leave everything on the table and we
said we did everything we could do to
try to get there you know like I said my
life is life is really precious and it's
showing us that a lot of space yeah yeah
you know and and then the day is well
you know as this business says it's just
a movie business you know it's things I
think I'm very serious but I don't take
myself seriously money he's 13 cell
series you've got problem you know
do serious you know Perez's the movie
business you know honest and it can it's
not worth but you know you know Sam I
was going to ask a question before you
go ahead he is feel being you know
independent filmmaker an actress in
Hollywood do you feel I've always wanted
to ask us and that environment you know
because you're in a world that you know
s movies and it's big movies you know
does it feel can i and you know that way
i think that way when I you know because
I was more scientist [ __ ] my first film
there you know I never could take me see
much you know because it was like on the
beach Santa Monica all these crazy
people when shooting trying to get
through in trade grab the camera people
would you know I never saw Hollywood and
such but do you get that feeling that M
because I don't want to phone me because
I love their meet they get the draw
between in the pen but there were the
studio so they feel that and maybe want
to try the studio's do you get a draw
towards that sate where you want to try
Studios are mainstream or because you're
in that environment does it affect you
in any way you know and that how do you
stop what only I can depend spirit even
though you're in Hollywood if you get 1
min there yeah for me I think our focus
for me I mean film courage is my focus I
don't I don't go on audition so I mean I
I enjoy acting but I'm not chasing that
but in terms of like being in the studio
system I don't think I would fit in and
and I I'm not gonna try to pretend to so
I think there's a clear it's not the
work ethic that I just think that you
know I'm not into being bound by so much
I think what goes along with that and I
don't have the pedigree to be involved
in in the studio so I don't have a
feeling that they would ever come
knocking on my door so I don't think
that's something that I I aspire to I'd
rather do something of ours on our own
and great if it makes money but it's
also fun to do in the meantime
so I think we like building something
and seeing it grow that's at least my
thing I shouldn't speak so I was gonna
say you know I think you know Kara and I
are just like a lot of young people you
know we're we're that lure of Hollywood
certainly draws you in yeah and
I think we have both come to Los Angeles
because of that Lord only to discover
that really at the end of the day you
know we're both sort of round up people
you know we you know we like we like to
do it our way but like we like to build
it from the ground up it's hard to
necessarily look at the studio system
and say yes that's exactly we're going
to be we're not never nicely going to
limit ourselves either but you know I
think I think we like I think you like
to build it from the from the ground up
and and so you know I think that's
interesting because we're here you know
and I guess what's great about what
we've done it is we're here a lot of
people aren't here you know it's you
know we have access to so many brilliant
people that are in LA so I was thinking
yeah yeah oh yes so so many creative
people all around us and so you know
while we're trying to figure out things
ourselves we're able to meet a lot of
these people were able to talk to them
to learn from their experiences and then
we've been able to do is sort of capture
that in a bottle and share that you know
through film courage you know we've been
able to do that with our radio show with
our website and so I guess that's also
part of we are now where we're we're
creative people we like doing things you
know we're also servants you know we're
servants you know we're yeah that's why
I love the biggest show you know because
of it I'm not I'm not big fan of people
telling people what you do and how you
do this when they're doing you know well
of the big issue was clear studies it
was people that done stuff they were
seeing that experience and that's what
visually attractive a bit of show where
you know what people will they do less
than do that I never done a great deal
and buy my book because I've done a
movie 20 years ago and I know about
movies so by my bootless or not know you
know you need people that do this manner
today you know this one finger on the
pulse pulse and you know and you the
people on that word or not you know and
that's why cuz I like to just learn by
mistakes you know I put my hand and a
fire screen you know what she's so
stupid I like to feel you know
violate to listen to people and has
plenty of feelings play that's business
that's like this field you know but
listen to people I've done it you know
that yeah and just thinking through a
main field is they don't do they're not
wrong because you're gonna lose a leg
there
Frenchy's was four [ __ ] fingers there
don't get in that path it's like a main
field as business and if you can learn
feature and that's what you are
I want your shirt done you know and so
you know just to fight you for that
because I never really have you know mmm
that's kind of what was for us as well
too was we I think and that's how it
grew is that we got excited hearing
these people's stories and and a lot of
times we just wanted to go in the studio
and just have them sit back and tell us
and not really even have to do much
talking so it was for a long time it was
like therapy for us but I liked what you
said you know just kind of capturing
this stuff in a bottle that was a great
analogy
thank you thank you yeah no that's
that's one thing we love about being
here that lame you know we loved we
loved the access so it's all these
brilliant people you know and and you
know more recently you know we've
stopped doing la talk radio and we've
sort of you know taken our show on the
road sort of say you know like you know
with a little video camera so yeah it's
been great because we're able to sort of
practice with with the camera more you
know set up shots and the tighter trying
to get the best shots that we can but
you know we're going to people's homes
and we're meeting some pretty yes yeah
it's been really cool yeah don't get me
wrong if you're ever in LA and you want
to do a show la talk radio is definitely
a great place to go um well we just felt
that it was time for us to move on and
that we were locked into a certain time
and all of that came every Sunday and
yeah you got more freedom that's weird
you know a constant yeah yeah yeah yeah
so we're having a good time yeah yeah so
you know yeah do you have any other
questions on our on our goodbye promise
release or would worship and plan after
and the global do you have a plan and
that you're going to do after one just
curious you know and that you're gonna
yeah are you gonna sell it from a
website you're going to try and put on
iTunes as well or as you go apply
another idea you know yeah no we're
still trying to figure this out you know
and I think hopefully to answer the
we'll be revealed in the next couple
weeks here but tell me something we
certainly had in mind all along is we
have our original Kickstarter backers
but you know yourself included that we'd
like to get a DVD copy out to so at some
point you know after this release we
like to sit down
finalize the DVD we just we just want to
get a DVD copy out to all of our backers
you know you know we'd love to get it
onto additional platforms also but you
know I you know ya know I cannot stand
on the sigmaj screen at the moment you
know in slash Evanescence shoulda
thought I you know just curiosity again
are you gonna I was asking her to watch
some of the other videos where I don't
my forget second name and likes you
yeah he's talking about other parents in
yeah are you gonna put other packs on
are you gonna keep it the one two
dollars or you know and you know you
know I think in terms of the the perks I
think I think we you know through care
and I sort of going back and forth on
sort of how we want to shape the
IndieGoGo campaign I think we've done
well then it's actually the perfect way
to do it you know at least for us you
know maybe for other people that come
along after us and you know maybe a
little experiment with a couple other
things you know for us we want to keep
it really simple
you know I you know Karen was the one
that says you really wanted like you
know something more than a dollar and I
think you know we're experimenting with
the one dollar two dollar and she also
wanted to cap off the limit at a hundred
you know so the first 100 people have an
opportunity to get the film for a dollar
and I think what we'll do after this is
we want to keep people accessing the
film very easily so we'll probably
introduce a second one dollar reward I
don't know if we'll call it like early
birds
- or maybe we'll call it early lions or
early Tigers or something like that and
instead of doing a hundred backers will
do will do maybe it's down to like 50 so
this now it's only 50 people that can
get that or work for a dollar and we'll
kind of keep that window tight and I
guess we'll just keep doing that over
and over again because it gives us a
very interesting device it's like all of
a sudden when that when that dollars
used up like
right now if you have like 50 spots left
or something but eventually it's gonna
wind down and then we'll be able to
promote the fact that like hey there's
only ten slots remaining for you to get
it for a dollar you know so then we'll
get some people to jump on board and
then that'll disappear and then we'll
reset the next one and then that will go
down and be like hey guess what only ten
thoughts remain if you give a dollar and
it becomes something that we can content
create that scarcity and then we have
one that's it's like the premium it'll
be probably in the forty nine dollar
range would be a mousepad
that that you can get with the film I
was trying to trap the late fees on
their current because some of these
perks it's a great idea
but but I mean how many people really
buy t-shirts I need to say it yeah yeah
Tony I'm stunned
you know you have this small little
movie that no one's ever heard of and
yet I want a t-shirt of that movie it's
just like you know I think we have to
make it into something that's larger or
something that has like you know that
reaches more people before it's like
we're going to commit to a coffee mug or
a t-shirt and movie poster it's just
like you know it's not you know I think
we've all them from Kickstarter
IndieGoGo as well like I'm preparing a
Kickstarter forsaked oh boy and you go
through and you really think best thing
a bit non-physical items but at the same
time you don't want to shortchange
people that you know you're trying to
keep the physical stuff and tell the
higher praises you know so when I saw
the one door to ho
this is actually one of the perks yeah
later okay that's worth at least 50
bucks yeah it's the $50 part about perks
you were yeah no no I was just seeing it
because we've all had experience
IndieGoGo and Kickstarter
we do really think about the tape
effects that we're doing these days we
are you're trying to do no in physical
items because you're thinking about what
the cost that's gonna come off then
we're on a post so you're trying to get
more inventive with perks you know and
again use I've kept it very simple which
is I can seen it it's all upside than
that because there's no physical items
are most mats are you know and people
really don't really think they want that
stuff anyway you know and I think in the
future we were higher perks as well you
know if people can get some experiences
and films you know like with a come on
is something there's no physical part
you know I think we go to $50 you have
to give a physical part but you know but
in twenty five dollar range I've saw
some campaigns where they've stopped
they stopped giving the DVD $25 but if
the goal or a cool stuff and now there's
worth $25 you know so I think it's that
bounce you know and so that's why I can
totally see the attractive say that we
use have done because it's cognate or
that other stuff you know and because as
a faint balance but I think when I start
to learn to do these campaigns with what
we need to take you know and be more
strategic about you know guess where
we're coming from is you know a big part
of this release is just to let go of the
ego you know it's just like yeah we
realized we didn't have any production
budget to make this film it's really
small
we're not out here saying like this is
the best film you're gonna see this year
at the same time we can say look you
know you know Gary Goldstein of the LA
Times he doesn't just do review so many
times he's also ya know it is yeah yeah
the producer of Pretty Woman he's the
producer under siege I mean he's his
movies have made over a million dollars
at the box office and he has seen our
little movie
it really touched them in you and you
really loved it so it's just like so we
know where the movie stands we're not
trying to have some de colo thinking
like this is a sundance film or whatever
it's just like you know for us you know
I guess I just want to say that and then
in terms of what the perks should be is
just like hey we the perk is as the film
is done you know and we're the first one
yes that's that that's that's the point
I think people are more concerned but
are you gonna do ECG we're gonna do with
the money make phone you know and start
your career and you don't start I think
that's what people really want do I see
you're gonna do you see you're going to
give it a shot with a lot of money do
you have and you've done that you know
and so yeah we don't need a ton of perks
we did we have the movie the movie
itself hopefully is a little bit of a
perk you know and we're trying to
capture our story and share the story so
if anyone wants to like sort of follow
the journey or or learn maybe a little
bit of the year their terms of how we
approached our release because we feel
like not only are we releasing the film
but we feel like we're we're engaging
with people and we're capturing their
story we're being very transparent with
you know it's why you know we can't hide
it you know you see very clearly exactly
where we stand in terms of how many how
many people have contributed you know
that's how many sales we have and you
can see exactly how much money's coming
from that you can do the average in
terms of how what the average donation
is and that all that that's all there in
front of you we're not trying to hide it
we just want people to see the film we
want to share the work and and see where
that takes us and we believe in the
power of building that snowball and
pushing it for we believe in the power
of you know because it really really
it's kind of frustrating when you see a
movie that you really like you know
maybe at a film festival or in a limited
theatrical release and it's like you
want to tell the people about it yeah
but you really can't because it's not
available anywhere you know so we want
you know just one day where when people
see the movie it's like hey this movie
is pretty cool check it out and then BAM
it says it's only a dollar like there's
no there's no friction there's no
there's nothing to slow it down it's
like if someone likes it they enjoy it
they can share it I think that's
important lose my ego aspect because
I've not found me because over the years
I slowly Cannes Festival years ago and I
hang out with filmmakers before social
media
youssef do here in my movie I've gotta
do what a sales agent it's gonna be
alliance Keys going on the shelves here
non-selling about on DVD at the time now
I go what did you meet Connor you know
we're never getting money we've got it
four thousand pounds but what get more
work out there and half the Tama never
gonna ever get this is different because
it's like the transparency SP it was a
lot filmmakers hate that sure and they
really don't get any money we're here
your Cena you know you and the fella
you're building the audience probably
better than I what fell me because they
call me some festivals and gather we you
know you're getting direct to the
audience so you know I think I want Towe
make us late to hate and give the
impression that you know them better
than the out but we all know this is
tough you know and so yeah you know and
that's great today you can have a great
film and I think I think really you know
if you're doing well with the film and
if the films reaching people and if it's
generating the revenue I think you'd see
a lot more people who are really
talented I mean yeah there's some great
filmmakers out there some people far
more talented than myself that never
want to make that next project you know
so how is it that they have such passion
to make this movie and they do it so
wonderfully and yet it just ends and
they never want to make another film
like what's going on they're like what
are we listening like you know so yeah
so we're just like hey you know we
realized what we have and we just wanna
we just want to share it we want to put
other people in position to share it and
we felt it would just be more exciting
to do it that way
yeah no I mean totally you know know
what what's the what's the one
Kickstarter IndieGoGo project that's
really blown you whether you've seen the
last couple years bad I'm trying to get
you sorry I'm trying to get a screen
back here yeah and that s projects that
wouldn't love you know I've been
impressed by them non film projects as
well you know there's much any
particular project aside
because I come back to this thing I
don't think it's a bet you know I've
seen people that I've made a great film
just that you've said in the past and
they disappeared and then when he a job
and it's like they had talent I see that
every day
see I cuz I'm the next Marlon Brando's
Mississippi up they can't hack it you
know
so what impresses me is the people is
stuck with the people that keep moving
the people with a tenet for they the
long stretch in the marathon it's what I
do individuals I get impressed by it
rather than particular films you know
because it's more to do with that when I
see somebody's getting that huge bug and
rolling up the sleeves and they're gonna
call the food to the very end and even
if the they know that they may not get
any we have a stove on a team they've
decided to take it they and this
individuals impress me rather particular
movies because there's so many good
movies out there but the solo will take
me see them as well when life you know
I've come up Netflix and those movies
they're everywhere so many bad movies as
well it's what it do it individuals I
get impressed by you know and then I
think as the years go on we're gonna see
those individuals were gonna see a body
of work I don't think we've had enough
time on Lane to see our body work
because you take Clint Eastwood during a
movie we are I see a monkey this an
orangutan you know everywhere every
which way but loose you go
I don't think he's gonna be inflate
American cinema I don't think he's going
to be a really big influence in America
some it's gonna be Scorsese a core plot
and look what something Eastwood you can
never defy anybody for what they've done
at last minute
you can never package the money a box in
it or I know who they are not the really
boys until you see a body of work and I
think it's gonna be ten years ten that
there were they start it's the end of
the juice because their body of work and
their endurance cuz everybody's at what
people start trying to fight to get to
via and you get to their whatever that
has in Hollywood whatever and then the
tape are done because they make bad
decisions doing commercial movies
because they the one about money you
know you these pre act does that is
something that's Julia movies and great
for me because and the study got out way
you're going to get a new tape of from
me cuz it doesn't take that road at all
and over ten years they're going to
bought a great body of work it's
completely different and I'm not gonna
get suggest by that so what I'm more an
individual you know ik you know
like Gregory beam and you know it's a
big array but this most alarming guys
like that we have they get you know when
yous guys you get it you should want to
be here for a long time
you know Oklahoma Ward he gets he he's
gonna be a for a long time you know so I
think it's over the next few years that
it's me personally is compressed by the
individuals and as all other people here
that have mentioned those too many to
mention you know and they did it they
the couple that done in and got an
Eminem avenged to speak to them and was
they just disappeared Internet was it
Inc jamming in Kyle yeah yeah yeah yeah
and you know I was really impressed but
in you know and yeah this is where
amazing yeah yeah yeah yeah no yeah no
we feel the same way you do David and
that's where this is so great because we
love taking the opportunity to take time
out connect with a kindred spirit that
sort of you know that's kind of doing
the same kind of stuff we're doing that
that shares a lot of the same thoughts
that we have you know that the evolution
you know work we're sort of we're
growing on this on this new frontier
together yeah you know we can kind of
look around and and just just I guess
just be inspired and I'll just just have
that respect and at the same time be
inspired that someone else out there is
putting that time and putting that
hustling and I think llandaff each other
make mistakes and learn features
mistakes you know and it's just you know
and this I think it's good to Kate
that's way because it's easy it
misunderstood only we all get messed
understand each other you know in some
ways I know how blog post things and
people say he's an [ __ ] when it's
like okay when you really mean it's
really difficult you know are you
laughing carried because I've got work
post wise as minute call me he sounds
like a rails when I see things that
tongue-in-cheek usually noise serious as
a seaman but you know and that's why
it's good to communicate that's we
sometimes because people can start to
see each other some of the videos that
you spoke to Ross prudent and other
people you get
they are idea people you know when you
see them on video as well you know which
is great great Tom T's you know sorry
you said you were gonna release your
next Kickstarter on in October
yeah I'd went and ID went with another
credit fund site and I knew the first
week I knew the first week it was a
mistake because when you wanted a player
it's not down in the platform because
it's a business platform for investment
because I was after more money and I
don't think I could raise the level of
money that needy don't Kickstarter
because I don't have a big enough follow
and so I so try this investment platform
because couple individuals could invest
that large amount of money but it's such
a different from Kickstarter because we
know Kickstarter walks an IndieGoGo
works because of the crowd because
people in small amounts of money then
become a markers on this platform
somebody gets five thousand they
disappear the mother from what he you
can't communicate with them the same way
they don't get behind and s and anybody
from the US I've got what US laws can
invest in that
so idea right away it was like I think
it creative because there was no perks I
knew right away that this is not a way
to do that you know so and I got big
investor interested but they don't know
hey that's all you're gonna give your
content I mean for free and they don't
they don't care that they don't know
that's new world you know I said yeah
back in monetize that's way you know
potentially so I've where that go
because I don't wanna and it was three
months she came three months along you
can't sell it for any less
and I mean that's just growing and it's
fun push me people who said yeah but we
can't do long Mia because well you know
and so I let it go because it was it was
just the wrong way ago you know and then
you just say I made a mistake there
start again but you know so probably a
towbar you know beginning to Allah
I'm making sure that I prepare really
prepare well and really get a vision for
this whole world and values every day
and you know it's the preparation these
guys know you know and stuff so yeah
probably toolbar end of September so
when does Kickstarter officially go to
England my windows out of the
yeah it goes then I think it's a song
time I don't know what deep and I'll do
it that way but because I've get they
Oklahoma Ward I'm gonna have him do
morning stories and this say yes and
then I started that partnership we have
in Kickstarter if you've got a you there
so I creative partnership you can you
can do that you know because I've done
that screen that's why I can do Emma for
hasn't came yet and but Kickstarter eat
root I won't be trying to release the
level of budget I was trying to get
before slightly war than not you know
and so we'll see how it goes
and I'm gonna do something miss screen
with that nap you know as well where
it's like a preview screen to horror
fans you know kind of summer you know
I'm not the least in the movie that we
but it's like a preview say Odawa so
people can see how you I make all these
movies for that price well if you like
it screen I had no money on that before
thousand dollars to make it was
resources and people helping you know
and I'll get people an idea that it's
never cost you hundred thousand dollars
to make but it looks pretty expensive so
people could see the movie foresee a go
and they go ray I go he's trying to do
it you know and so that'll be I saw a
preview that de Velde horror blogs and
horror fans towards as well you know and
and then I released screen you know at
the end the years a few options and as a
drive and option a DIY I've got a couple
of ideas with that you know but they say
a sudden one is getting over the next
since he of course you know it's just
been a preparation and a proper
preparation that's a you know cuz I'm
gonna try and risk we're about money
yeah baby thank you for taking time out
we know anyway thank you yes later you
are it's nighttime there we're gonna
we're gonna swing back over and try to
see if we can continue to spark Jack
marchetti's campaign and push that
forward I'm gonna push you as well yeah
nice to see you face to face here this
is great so yeah no it's good it's good
yes I forget all miss beans like two and
a half years three years you know yeah
just once
lost in the grind you know you get lost
and you know it it's hard for us to
believe it's been as long as well no
we're just young
yeah yeah okay thanks thanks we talk
peace and then I'll be pushing your
campaign when this one's over as well so
push it right to the engine
all right thanks we're lucky to have you
yeah thank you thank you thanks sketches
later all right